all right thank you sherry one of the
biggest struggles and lessons of the
time is prioritizing mental health
just as much as physical health we have
expert melody parker here to help us
navigate this balancing act that we call
life
welcome to the show melody hello thank
you for having me
of course of course so first things
first there's just so much to do and so
little time with so much going on around
us so
where do we start what's your suggestion
so here are some quick tips just to know
how about writing out everything that it
is that you want to do
and that could be a long list of things
prioritize your short term and your long
term goals
what's realistic what's a wish list and
the things that are realistic
let's start narrowing them down what can
i do today
and it's maybe only one thing but can i
do that thing
well and after i do that thing well can
i move on to the next thing it's about
being present and in the moment
and am i managing my time right so when
i get up in the morning and i know that
i have several things i need to do
okay there are only 24 hours in a day
and am i
efficiently going to be effective
throughout those 24 hours
maybe not so maybe i just set aside some
time to get some things done
oh okay i'm taking notes over here and
of course obviously the times have been
really stressful for everyone for
different reasons what are some things
that we can do
to relieve that stress so to release
some stress
it's all about learning how to
experience things
now so i mentioned being in the present
a great acronym is deer
you want to drink not the good drink but
drink
plenty of fluids that are going to
hydrate you drinking a lot of water
you want to eat exercise and rest
everybody is always on the go go go go
go and with the pandemic
maybe it has slowed us down but you want
to take time to relax relate and release
doing some deep breaths doesn't hurt to
meditate to pray
just acknowledge where you are and say
okay you know what this is what i can
control
even if it's just very very small and be
in tune with yourself and so before i
leave
let's just take some deep breaths we're
going to take a deep breath in through
our nose
okay holding for a few seconds and then
release so we're going to do it together
are you ready i was already doing it
girl
i know make sure you're letting the air
go into your stomach okay
okay so just three deep breaths and oh
one more thing on the last third breath
you want to be able to tighten up every
muscle so we're going to get kind of
ugly
we're going to tighten up our face and
then when we release out of our mouths
we're going to let it go so you ready
deep breath in through your nose
hold it
now release oh i already went see that's
my problem
i gotta listen you gotta listen thank
you so much i'm gonna work on that i
really want to add that to my routine so
thank you so much
when you wake up and when you end your
day 30 seconds that's it
absolutely thank you so much if you want
to get in contact with melody you can
find her on facebook by searching
mending broken pieces counseling i love
that name and consulting services
las vegas thank you melody